le décor est le même l'intention est
l'ambition ne change pas une année s'est
écoulée les départements des
hauts-de-seine et des yvelines soit
toujours plus se rapprocher et pour en
convaincre l'auditoire d'un soir le
bilan est dressé à création d'une
société d'économie mixte mise en commun
du patrimoine routier ou encore du
service d'archéologie préventive
malgré les difficultés administratives
qui n'ont pas manqué malgré le
scepticisme politique eh bien nous
considérons que nous avons fait avancer
l'intérêt de nos deux départements dans
la même direction c'est à dire dépenser
mieux dépenser moins pour un résultat
identique voire supérieure pour le
projet commun 2017 verra la création
d'un foyer médicalisé pour autistes
cette année sera celle aussi de
l'accélération après les échéances
électorales en fin d'année les deux
assemblées départementales débattront de
la fusion pour une mise en application
dans les années suivantes et ce malgré
les voix dissonantes concernant le
projet le président de la république sur
sa table de nuit à dessiner les
nouvelles régions
quels bouleversements d'un seul coup que
la gauche n'a rien dit nous nous faisons
ça progressivement en y prenant le temps
la séance
la gauche est indignée elle a une
indignation un peu sélective non à terme
la fusion des deux départements pourrait
permettre la création d'un super
territoire doté d'un budget de 3 4
milliards d'euros soit l'équivalent de
la métropole du grand paris qui regroupe
la capitale et les trois départements
limitrophes